your internal blocks and limiting
personal beliefs are holding you back
from becoming the entrepreneur that you
were born to be hi I'm Evelyn Carmichael
and I believe that hungry entrepreneurs
deserve help so today I'm asking a
question from one of the people who
bought my worksheets named Shiraz and
Shiraz retain saying she wants to create
a website to help entrepreneurs overcome
their internal blocks and induce an
internal drive towards excellence and
she wanted my advice on how to do this
online thanks for the question Shiraz
this is an awesome business I love this
concept the things that hold
entrepreneurs back it's not lack of
money it's not lack of resources it's
not what gender you are it's not what
country you're born in it's the belief
that those things hold you back limiting
personal beliefs are holding you back if
you look at any entrepreneur in the
world how they got started you look at
the famous ones the ones who had a lot
of success it was hard entrepreneurship
is hard period and it doesn't matter
where you come from or who your parents
are or how much money you had the most
successful entrepreneurs in the world
are often the ones who came from
absolutely nothing absolutely nothing
they didn't have the world handed to
them on a plate but they also didn't
believe that anything was holding them
back any shortcomings they had in their
life they believed that they could go
out and accomplish it
I love this concept and if you're gonna
do it online my advice first of all is
try to create a resource a directory the
first create awareness first step is
awareness because too many entrepreneurs
they're not aware that they have limited
personal beliefs they believe that
they're too old to start a business and
so they don't start a business or they
do but they'll believe that they'll
never be really successful because
they're too old or too whatever so you
have to find a way to let them know you
share articles you share examples you
share stories you tell them that guys
like Ray Kroc from McDonald's didn't
start McDonald's that was in his 50s
Colonel Sanders didn't start Kentucky
Fried Chicken toads in his 60s is
possible if you believe it's possible so
if it were me and created an online
directory a resource guide for all the
different limiting personal beliefs sort
of the most common ones that you're
finding for entrepreneurs step two is
equipment to change its understanding
that you have this limiting personal
belief and you want to change it so
making them fill out a form making them
acknowledge that they have this limiting
personal belief and that they want to
make a change and then third you need to
have a way to reinforce it because some
of these beliefs are so ground into us
they're so ground into you it's been
years and years and years of believing
this it's hard to make a change in an
instant one day you might be really
motivated and really believe you're on
top of the world and then the next day
you're back in the dumps you had a bad
day and you're back to thinking no I'm
too old I'm not gonna make this happen
so you need to share with these people
resources on an ongoing basis share with
them success stories share with them
examples share with them famous
entrepreneurs as well as people from
your site and fight success
keep that positive reinforcement going
and if needed maybe they can sign up for
a coaching call with you or coach that
you really enjoy working with then that
could be a revenue model for you an
opportunity to drive no new business for
your company
you're definitely targeting a market
that is absolutely needed to many
entrepreneurs just don't believe in
themselves fully they're holding
themselves back you are holding yourself
back with your limiting personal beliefs
if you can answer the following question
and say I won't succeed because whatever
is in there that's holding you back and
it shouldn't because you can't achieve
it you can go after any goal you want
it's only in your head if you think you
can you can good luck thanks to the
question let me know how it goes does
I'm really interested I might post some
articles on there or share some
expertise I'd love to help out if I can
for those of you watching if you like
the video please give it a thumbs up
below
I love seeing those coming and if you
have a question about this video or
question for your own business feel free
to leave it in a comment section below I
always read those and I love seem to
come in so thank you and I'll see you on
the next episode
you